[Music]
let's go to mankato mankato
minnesota and talk to chelsea did i say
that right
yes mankato
yes oh my gosh i'm incredible i should
do this for a living all right so what's
up how can i help
um okay so
i'll just start with my question for you
my husband and i have a special needs
daughter
and she's completely dependent
and i guess i've been struggling between
wanting
like personal accomplishments in a
career
and devoting myself to her
and i guess i'm just looking for some
insight on how i can find
a balance that's most beneficial for
everyone in the family
that's tough
tough
what's the special need
um she has kind of a multitude of
different things
she has a really rare
uh syndrome
and in addition to that
she's autistic she's non-verbal she has
a feeding tube
yeah it's just kind of
new
since last year that she
lost her hearing after meningitis
so and there's a lot of different things
that we have to do for her on a daily
basis just for
um to get her through the day yeah
this is a this is a hard question um i
want to um so
tell me say i don't really want to talk
about that and that's no problem
um what is her prognosis is this
terminal how long does she have
um it's it's
more of a mental
or um psychological and neurological
yeah
um so it's really unknown
because there's really only about 20
people in the entire world that have her
syndrome
so there's just not very much science
behind it
as to where you know where her life is
going to lead and they all have a
variability of um
you know disabilities and abilities okay
man
so how old is she
she is eight eight
do you
do you struggle with guilt
do you struggle with
we did this
um i guess i
probably not guilt
but
maybe a part of me hasn't fully accepted
all of the
the things that she has to go through
every day
and it seems like when she gets over one
thing it'll be another thing
that adds on top of it and it's
you know it's not something that i guess
i feel guilt with but
i just didn't expect it really and so
um you know i'm just trying to arrange
my life in a way that is
conducive to everybody in the family so
so you you hit on something so important
and if you haven't done this yet it
would make you just like ever most every
other parent in your situation i've ever
talked to
um
but i think it's the cornerstone and
again this isn't i don't have any neural
signs to back this up or anything like
that but i think this is the cornerstone
to turning that corner and
deciding what comes next
and you've heard me say this on the show
but grief is simply the gap between what
i hoped for what i wanted to happen and
what actually is happening
it's that picture that i thought was
gonna be
when we found out we were pregnant and
we found i was gonna be a little girl
versus the reality at eight years old
hears this kid and all of her struggles
and all of her pain and all of her hurts
and all of her frustrations and i'll say
it for you
i'm so pissed off
and i'm so annoyed and i'm so frustrated
and i'm exhausted and i miss my husband
and i miss just kicking my feet up and
watching tv and i miss
random sex on a saturday afternoon i
miss all those things because i've got
it's all of it right
and there's that gap
that we never stop and grieve and sit in
it
we just run to the next thing and run to
the next thing what happens is we run
for 8 10 15 20 years on adrenaline and
cortisol
and eventually our health takes a dive
our relationships melt as you mentioned
these dreams i had for myself these
career goals these things i wanted to do
i just let it all kind of
slowly drain out of the bathtub because
i never stopped to say
i wanted this i had this picture and
then this is what i've got
and now what right
most of us won't do that because we feel
like we're abandoning our kids or we're
bad parents for saying i wish you
weren't wheelchair-bound
i wish that you could get up and run run
and play i wish i didn't have to do all
this stuff because you have
um hearing impairment and you have
vision impairment and you have um an
inability to eat i i wish that we feel
like if we say that that we're
dishonoring our kid and we're not if we
don't say it we're dishonoring our own
bodies
okay
and so i think it's important to spend a
moment a season some time in that gap
and that gap is hard it hurts it's
brutal sometimes even saying it out loud
will set off every mom alarm you have
ever and your husband joins every dad
alarm you have
how is your marriage through this
it's good um
my so my daughter
um
she came into our marriage i had her
before i married my husband
okay um and so
he knew about her issues and things
obviously before we got married and he's
really
um
just kind of he'd dive right in to
help me out with everything and
pretty awesome guy huh yeah yeah that's
cool very cool
very cool so i would love to see you all
get together no kids no nothing you all
have other kids together
um we have a five-year-old son okay
normal just maniacal
bouncing off of things five-year-old
yes
that's fun so i would love to see you
all get together and do a
marriage checkup how are we how are
things what do you miss what do you not
like
often folks on either side of this
equation you know
mom dad whoever
get really invested in accomplishing a
bunch of tasks all day and couples can
accidentally find themselves as great
co-managers of their household
but really distant from one another so
i'd love to see y'all go to spend some
time together and just say where are we
checkup how are things we got another
diagnosis we got another challenge and
then we got meningitis on top of it and
we thought we're gonna lose her and now
she's lost her hearing so now we have
more challenges
where are we
and then grieve together and that might
be grieving together might be you
writing a letter him writing a letter
and y'all reading it to each other
here's what i wished
i wish this and it didn't happen
and then y'all can write that next one
together and i'm saying that one's that
one's more if you don't really have to
write a letter together but then y'all
say what's next and often i'm glad
you're not suffering from guilt often
what i hear for parents of kids
especially they feel guilty for wanting
to go to work they feel guilty for well
i want my career i feel guilty
i guess there is a little bit okay so
you do have a little bit of that i mean
i left my career um i was the lab tech
and
it just wasn't working because she has
to go to therapy and things and so it's
like i just don't
i had to have the flexibility
and so i almost felt like i was choosing
between
like
having the income or the success or
whatever i envisioned for myself and i
it's like i had to give that up
it sounds selfish but no no see and
that's um here's what i want you to be
really weary of and when you do some
writing on this for yourself when you
start writing yourself a letter to start
grieving this
you got to be curious not judgmental
okay
you have to say huh why why do i get so
mad when i think about the career i gave
up not i shouldn't be mad about my
career right i don't want you to to
start labeling
morality to these thoughts you're having
they're just your thoughts man
and they're they're a thousand percent
valid you're allowed to have those it's
got to be i can't imagine rap i get
frustrated when my kids like four
minutes late to the thing
right when they won't find their shoes i
can't imagine having to quit my career
that i loved or that i wanted to
go far in because
right that like that is natural it's
normal hiding that and squashing that
and trying to shut it down will eat your
body from the inside out
and that brings me to this
if you choose ultimately after you sit
down with your husband y'all talk about
what is and what's gonna be
if y'all say this is the season that
we're gonna try some in-home care and
i'm gonna go back to work
well i am working
i took a huge pay cut yep yeah so i
guess that's where i'm feeling it so i
want you to look at the math of this
like if if we have to get some in-home
nursing care or some in-home nanny care
or we have to ultimately send our
daughter to a home because we don't have
the resources to or the skill set what
to care for her
then
let's have that conversation let's have
that hard conversation that will be
brutal and gut-wrenching all that but is
this the reality of where we are
um i would suggest you you sound like
someone who would really struggle if no
she absolutely knows where she is she
knows who we are she knows all that
stuff
i just don't really want to deal with it
you sound like someone who will really
struggle with that is that fair
um
yeah i mean it's constantly on my mind
like i'm not completely opposed to it
um i've had to get used to
the idea of it
um just the fact that maybe she's not
going to be
in our home when we're not able to take
care of her anymore sure um
but
i've been trying to
um accept that i guess okay um lean into
that discomfort and leaning to the
discomfort of i may need to get some
help
three days a week i may need somebody
else to help drive and we're we are in a
privileged financial position to be able
to do that or we work really hard and
save on other things so that we can make
this happen
and that's going to give me some space
in my marriage it's going to give me
some space with my five-year-old it's
going to give me some space in my
professional career
but have the hard conversation most of
the time in these situations those
conversations stay very hypothetical and
one person sits on all of that until
they implode and then the a house is
just covered in contempt and resentment
and ash
i would love to see you have those kind
of like i really want to explore getting
some help
even if it's five hours a day for a for
somebody to come in skilled babysitter
or something to come in and help
or i wanna have a conversation about a
home i wanna have i wanna have that
conversation
um if you ultimately get down the road
and you say there's no way i'm leaving
my special needs kid
just so i can go sit in meetings all day
i'm not doing that that's insane
don't apologize for that either because
i've heard that side too like i feel
like i should be back at work but i
actually like being here and i had to
give a lot right so it's both and i want
to push on your one word though
you're probably not going to find
balance
that's mostly a myth it's not real
you will find what works for you in
particular seasons
you will never find an outfit that will
work for 365 days a year
sometimes you have to put on a coat
sometimes you have to
just wear a t-shirt sometimes you have
to go inside because it's hot
you'll never be able to find a system
that will work forever and so letting
that myth of quote-unquote balance go
between work and home that's just not
real what's real is in this season for
the next 24 months i'm gonna double down
and try to go back to work full time and
make a jillion dollars and i'm gonna try
the skilled nursing thing if we can
afford it i'm gonna give that a shot in
the season
and then if she has another medical
setback and she needs her mom then for
this season i'm going to go back to part
time and i'm going to stay at home
and if you look at it seasonally
then
nobody says winter's broken
when summer shows back up or nobody says
summer's broken when winter shows up
it's just the cycle it's just the way it
goes i want you to
think of what's happening in y'all's
world the same way
what is the next 24 months think in
short-term cycles what's the next 24
months what's the next 36 months what's
the next year what does that look like
for us right now and then what can i do
right now
to be successful in that area and that
might mean you got to say no to some
stuff that might mean that i'm going to
spend less time with her and you know
push some push over to somebody else
i would lean lean towards that road and
i would let the word balance just let
that go it's a myth it's a vapor it's
not real and we kill ourselves trying to
get it we buy a bunch of stupid day
planners with millions of ribbons in
them and all kind whatever
let it go let it go
you're a good mom and that baby girl's a
lucky lucky lucky to have you it sounds
like your job's lucky to have you too
go with your husband y'all pick this
thing apart spend some time in grief
spend some time in the pain of i wanted
that but this is
and then y'all can make some hardcore
decisions about what comes next